just before we launch into it what is
the distributive law i'll show you i'll
write it out quick
that's right okay so this is the easiest
way to demonstrate the distributive law
for you
a b and c they're just any numbers okay
so i'm calling on your understanding of
algebra
so that like if i give you an actual
example that's true for that
but this is true for any numbers so when
you see those brackets there
right you see two things number one
there's actually a multiplication sign
hiding in there right so a outside of
the brackets is short for
a times what's in the brackets okay now
here's where the distribution of the
distributive law comes from right
that multiplication that multiplication
is distributed among all the things
inside the brackets right just like okay
i've got pieces of paper exam
notifications and i distribute them to
everyone in the class
right there's the class and i give one
to each of the people
in there it just happens to be a small
class so
let's have a look at i'm going to give
you three problems that are very easy to
do
when you use the distributive law okay
so let's do this
let's do this and let's
do this okay
watch how i take advantage of the
distributive law okay
some of you might know what double of 47
is right away but if you don't see it
straight away
you can use the distributive law to help
you right watch
47 right 47 we have a place value system
that means that depending on your place
in the number the numbers mean different
things the digits mean different things
as opposed to say
the roman numeral system which it
doesn't matter where all those ones are
all the ones are the same they all mean
one and so that's three
but this four and seven they mean
different things right the four doesn't
mean
four what does it really mean yeah
yeah okay
that's exactly right this is the units
and this is the tens right
so really it's 40 plus 7. can you see
that
that's what 47 means okay now that is
being multiplied
by two and by breaking it apart i make
it easier to multiply
what's double the 40. it's 80.
what's double of 7 14.
that's simple 94.
very good okay all right let's move on
to the next one
a half times 192. now i don't know about
you
but 192 is a bit awkward in my head you
can break this up
in whatever way you like that makes it
easiest
personally i'm going to break it up like
this
i could break it up into all of its
parts into 100
and 80 sorry and 90 and 2. that would be
fine
but i don't need to because 180 is
really easy to
take half off and 12 is really easy to
take half off
what's half of 180
what's half of 18 because 18 is a small
number
it's 9 right so if i stick a zero on the
end i just stick a
zero on the end of that and half of
twelve is
six done okay
all right one last use of the
distributed law
this looks really gross right for sure
you'd reach for a calculator with this
but you don't have to watch i could
break apart the 17
but i'm going to be a little bit steep
sneaky and i notice
that 9 is very close to 10. i'm going to
write
9 as 10 minus 1
because it is 10 minus 1 right and that
makes it so simple
multiplying by 10's easy it's 170. you
just whack a zero with you
and multiply by one well i hope we can
multiply
by one okay so 170 minus 17. it's still
not
super straightforward but it's certainly
much easier than thinking
ah the nine the nine times seven is
going to be 63 capital
blah blah blah that's just going to be
sorry 153